So if you're going to hurt someone,
what do you think essentially is,
okay,
what would really hurt me?
And then you think,
well,
I'll just do that to them.
It's like that's,
that's,
that's a,
that's a good theory.
It's very sophisticated.
So anyways,
so,
okay,
so what happens,
Adam and eve wake up,
they weren't supposed to do this.
God told them that they are going to be sorry if they did that,
but they did it anyways because that's what people are like.
And because we always learn things that knock us out of our present paradises
right too.
We're curious and we won't leave things alone and maybe things are not so bad.
And then you,
you know,
ask some questions that maybe you're not so happy about asking.
Once you find the answer and you fall out of your little paradise into history
and you've got to work to set things right again.
Anyways,
God gets wind of this and,
and he chases Adam and eve out of the garden of Eden.
But he says some interesting things when he chases them out.
He says,
all right,
now you know,
what's the consequence of that?
And he says,
Dad,
him,
you're going to have to work.
Oh,
that's cool.
That's really cool.
What he has gone after all it also,
he,
he's,
he knows what he's talking about.
He says,
you're going to have to work.
So why would you have to work now that you knew you were vulnerable?
Well,
the answer to that is,
well,
if you know you're vulnerable,
that stretches out into the future,
you know you're going to die.
You know that you're fragile.
It's like maybe all your problems are solved right now.
You're all sitting here,
you're safe,
you're not hungry.
You don't want anything to drink,
et cetera.
But what about tomorrow?
What about next week or next month or 10 years from now?
It's like,
just because you got all your problems solved for this second doesn't mean
you've got him solved for the rest of your iterations through time.
So you've got to work.
And the work is the sacrifice of the present for the future.
And so that's exactly right.
You have to work now.
You see?
See what's interesting about that,
and this is the theory that I was,
oh,
and then of course God tells that Eve,
well,
you've really,
you know,
screwed things up too.
You're going to have these big brain babies and,
and that's our big problem.
You're going to suffer in childbirth and then they're going to be dependent on
you forever.
And because of that you're going to be dependent on this man that you just woke
up.
And that's not going to be very pleasant for either of you,
but tough luck.
And so that's it.
That's the curse in some sense.
And it's exactly right.
But the thing is,
there's a theory in there.
There's an interesting theory of suffering that's implicit in that story.
And the theory of suffering is that suffering is built into the structure of
self conscious big.
It's built right into the structure.
So if you're a self conscious being,
that's your lot,
it isn't someone else's fault.
It isn't a consequence of sociological oppression.
It isn't the,
it a consequences of the fact that our society isn't organized.
It's just part of being.
All right.
So that's a big deal because that's a,
that's an important theory because one of the questions is,
well,
we'll hit a,
why is there suffering and what are you going to do about it?
And it's a big,
it's a lot different if it's just the way it is for you and if it's actually
your fault that he's suffering,
those are,
or maybe it's the group's fault that you're suffering.
Those are major,
those theories are really,
really different.
And then in the second story in Kate enable,
MMM
cane make sacrifices to try to get it in good with God enabled make sacrifices
and the sacrifices are kind of archaic from our perspective.
They're burnt offering.
So the smoke goes up where God can detect it because he's up there somewhere up
there where the stars are and God rejects cane sacrifices and we don't really
know why,
but it kind of looks like Cain is a second grader.
And then God Cain goes and complains to God and says like,
what kind of stupid universe did you make here I'm breaking myself and half
trying to get things together,
making the proper sacrifices.
And nothing's going well for me and Abel.
Well,
you know,
he's,
everything he touches turns to gold.
Everyone loves him.
He's even a really good guy.
It's like so annoying.
What's up with this place you've built?
And God tells Kane,
don't become an and telling me that the entire fabric of reality is wrong
because it isn't working out for you.
Says Sin Crouches at your door,
like a,
like a sexually aroused predatory cat.
That's basically the metaphor that,
that God uses.
And he says,
and you let it in and had it and let it have its way with you.
And that's really an interesting way of putting it because what God says to Cain
is that,
you know,
you're all bitter and resentful and really it's no wonder,
because you know,
things aren't going well for you.
And then you've got able who's over shining you in every way.
And uh,
but yeah,
it's your fault.
This terrible thing waited at the door,
you let it in and then you entered into a creative union with it and you
produced something as a consequence.
And that's this tormented spirit that you have now.
And it's polluting your relationship with reality.
And that's why things aren't working so out very well for you.
So go put yourself together before you come and tell me just exactly what's
wrong with the structure of reality.
And Cain isn't very happy about that because really is that really what you want
to hear?
It's right.
Like you have more misery than is necessary because you really didn't put your
act together and you know it and you've done it creatively.
And so Kayden goes and kills Abel.
That's the story of how resentment enters the world.
And it's the first story in the Judeo Christian Canon,
let's say about actual human beings because and eve were made by God,
so they don't really count.
Cain and Abel were born.
And so that's something.
So there's a reaction to suffering,
right?
The necessity of sacrifice and the consequence of the necessity of sacrifices
that some sacrifices work and others don't.
And then if your sacrifices aren't met with the,
with the goodwill of God,
let's say,
well then that makes you angry.
Well,
of course it does.
You can take God out of the story if you want,
if you're not happy with that kind of mythological or narrative statement.
But it doesn't really matter because the whole point is is that if you make
sacrifices,
especially if they're second rate,
things aren't going to go very well for you and you're going to get bitter and
resentful and murderous and maybe genocidal.
And it's really interesting,
you know,
because Kane has descendants and if you bug,
if you transgress against them,
they don't just kill you,
they kill seven of you and then his later descendants kill 49 of you.
There's this exponential growth of murderousness as a consequence of canes,
primary primal fratricide.
And then the next story is the flood.
And that's not an accident is nothing in those stories is an accident.
Okay,
so now you got two different theories about the nature of suffering.
You've got the one I just laid out,
it's called the foundational story of suffering and malevolence.
And you have the marks,
a story,
which is while there's oppressed people and the reason they're all pressed in
suffering is because the oppressors are oppressing them.
Those are not the same theories.
Right?
And there's a utopianism that's implicit in Marxism,
which is if you could just get the damn oh pressers to stop oppressing the
oppressed,
then the utopia would arrive.
And so not only are the oppressors responsible for the suffering of the poor,
they're also responsible for the fact that the utopia isn't here for everyone.
And so how reprehensible can you get?
Well,
then that certainly justifies that degree of malevolence justifies pretty much
anything you'd like to do to them.